yeah welcome to this video playing
marvel marvel I don't know ma'am I
really don't know any French at least
French language um and let's see it's
very high rated five minute we got the
Greenfeld I'll play h4 no matter what
this is the current craze in listen top
level chess its own I'm quite weird but
the thing is that against the
gruenfelder why doesn't have it much
anyway so he's trying for this kind of
offbeat lines yeah this is a way to go
but then the question is is this really
good for black there are similar lines
where the bishop is on g500 k95 was the
normal way to play and never saw this
just just serve from the general concept
I mean of course I never saw this exact
position because but I have no idea
about that about the opening okay yeah
he still has this idea of 95 or 94 so
the question is do I have some clever
Lulu prevent that I could play something
like b-52 after which she probably will
take c5 what about age 5
if he takes with the night and move like
you for this is crazy ah come on it's on
let's let's do this now maybe maybe
night XD 5 a son is now more more
dangerous interesting now I can play
maybe not XD five now Queen takes Bishop
takes Bishop d2 is the normal on reply
but maybe he's got rope the eighth in
this position yup exactly
yeah I probably need to take it don't
think I have any any other move maybe we
should be too it's not completely
terrible but what god I was thinking
about Queen d5 bishops III check bishop
d to look the eighth maybe rook takes
the Queen takes d8 sucking the Queen and
then Bishop c3 you isn't this an idea
playing for the Aged file okay okay so
the shifty to rocky eight rock the end
hmm I can like play a crew g5 maybe it's
not clear why this should work but I'm
also curious about the queenside divide
if i play am Bishop takes you three will
take with the Queen the bishop yeah that
probably deserve completely ridiculous
just like the Queen I mean it's like
it's fun let's let's try this it's a
it's really a nice bishop on c3 and I've
got h five minute everything's and set
up to for the stew to to maybe work and
it's probably not good enough for for
correspondence chess but then it's still
interesting that can get you can get
done tricky for Blackie i'm pretty sure
about that if i take on g6 the next
mistral he needs to take with the f
phone and then something like III and
Bishop c4 is really flowing nicely
besides takes an IG 5 can be an
immediate problem I also always have
worked in one with the temple I don't
need to Castle here anymore longer in
King is ok only one yeah okay probably I
need to need to take and maybe bishop is
six some yeah I am but I have liked
night 35 let's say a 4-bit should be six
I've got 95 so very annoying move and
I'm not sure one who do I want to play
and like this more it's probably also
better it's a game 95 now and it's a
mattock 95 years good good as well
yeah I cannot take okay Jade and that
sounded slightly tricky here yeah look
the 80 is there something something
better okay the rocket III Brooke
teavana when Rob t1 and Tenley taking a
drug the age when you can do knight c6
but take that's not not so convincing I
can play look look aged six of course
which isn't isn't so bad
what if I played the very direct b3
intending to take a plate of C phone
what is he doing against that all rook
age for maybe rook age for to prepare
that what take a drug age four and I
don't want to exchange the night so when
so early yeah it's all looking a rather
promising I could also cancel long don't
think it's helping too much of it I
could do it yeah come on I need to any
Jonathan at some point of course now it
could take on g5 and give back the queen
but it should be good for me and its
opponent the position i'm not sure what
he's moving now I'm threatening 96 if he
yeah this is smooth but I can I can
attack it with luke t 1 and I don't
really believe he can take and take on
on a to the sir would really surprise me
if he could can't afford that if he
covers it I just take it Quincy 6 group
takes d5 now maybe he can take on 80 f I
don't I don't see a direct refutation at
the moment I thought rook age 60 some
possible but it's not clear if the Sun
is so convincing well I don't see a
better move at the moment
okay maybe add something better it's not
not easy at all yeah yeah I wondered
about this can I take on this out now or
is this terrible takes rook g7 king
evade it looks it looks like white
should have something here I can't help
now looky seven takes on g5 don't really
have a decisive move them they are Luke
age six is to draw but it feels like
there should be something
don't don't see don't see it oh yeah
maybe I should have canceled long and I
would have ideas like Bishop c4 check
each one not sure that it's winning but
itself it's interesting he still doesn't
threaten to take this
I need the ship's e-flat check but i
cannot i cannot get this in I was I'm
even thinking about rock to d6 which
looks completely insane Adam rookies
haven't takes rook g6 is this this may
be the way to to go op should be three
we are by now it's it's difficult to to
not accept the draw I'm down on three
minutes
rookie form yeah I problem down to two
minutes and I don't see a clear solution
let's see yeah I'm winning with rookie
for Jesus Christ yeah actually saw this
move right at the end that this is
probably the last way to do it and this
is winning brooke d 2h form yeah yeah
okay and wins this is great okay Jade
mate mmm and he's completely pentium
just winning ah and I wanted to gamble
at the anti I didn't I didn't want to I
mean I wanted to do it but the time and
everything ah rookie for ya no move it's
gonna move brooke d 2h form yeah this
would have been great huh did I have
something better before I mean this is
where it really looks like a like a
shaky position Brooke age 6 now the
computer wants to go look aged 6 cm
winning brooke edge force winds
interesting so i wasn't so bad and long
castles wins
yeah I had the suspicion that this is
better afterwards here because now I'm
actually able to use the rook on them on
h1 I can just play Queen it Bishop e2
intending this andrew cage one and I'm
winning computers on + 6 cm what chance
what a chance then the quilt second
wasn't so ridiculous at all at least you
can play it computer wants to play g5
here this is this is difficult to play
yeah unfortunately I mr. miss this is
win here a 97 should be played according
to the engine and this losses due to
this fantastic group d 4 news I saw it
right at the end that this is an idea
but I didn't then I started to calculate
a bit and I thought okay I've got two
minutes ah whatever take the draw this
is the relatively toughest defense
according to computer but it's it's it's
just over just over yeah yeah I hope you
liked it's the 19 move draw is a bit
weird in an online rapidshare so what
can I do I should have should have yeah
I would have worn with Ruby for what I
didn't find it in in the in the time
that I'm gonna have yeah thanks for
watching